hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development last week on Android
developers live Roman Nick and Adam
hosted the record-breaking premiere of
Android design in action taking a look
at these three transit apps and giving
them a full you I makeover on the Friday
games review Dan Galpin was joined by
returning co-host E&E Lewis for a look
at these games in a no holds barred game
review showdown on the App clinic Ian
and I put timer stopwatch apses under
the microscope the video for each of
these broadcast is now available on
YouTube you can find links to all of
last week's broadcasts our entire back
catalogue in the schedule for this
week's shows at Google developers live
that's developers.google.com/live /
android this week we have seven shows
for your viewing pleasure starting with
Android developer office hours
broadcasting live from London Mountain
View and Sydney on Tuesday Android
design an action would be back at 1030am
eastern time to take a look at two of
the timer stopwatch apps we are viewed
on last Friday's app clinic join Nick
and Adam as they offer some alternative
UX implementations for impetus interval
timer and hybrid stopwatch on Thursday
we have the premiere of developer strike
back an opportunity for the developers
whose apps we pulled apart on the app
clinic and Android design in action to
respond to our candid feedback and let
us know a little more about the
challenges they faced building their
apps and how they overcame them on
Friday evenings breaking out his
prescriptions glasses and thumb ring for
an app clinic on camera and photography
apps we're coming to you at a brand new
time of 1030am pacific that's two and a
half hours earlier than normal there's
more to these apps and hipster filters
though so to be sure to visit the
moderator page linked here and nominate
your suggestions all sort of brand new
time is the Friday games review where
professional had enthusiast Dan Galpin
once again be joined by n I can't get
enough time on camera near lewes once
again this week there's no seem so hit
us up on the moderator page to nominate
any game for the guys to review in other
Android developer news you can catch
some Android developer advocates live in
person Rios ke Tony and anchor will be
attending the GDG soul made up on monday
at six pm and David Chandler will be
visiting the Richmond Java user group
this wednesday at five thirty in Android
documentation last week we saw the
publication of the new developer and
testing checklist threading
accessibility support to your apps as
well as the launch of filtering by the
bios ABI support for multi apk
distribution we also announce that
Android activation to hit the half
billion milestone and a happy to report
that the jelly bean statue is returned
to its rightful place in front of
building 44 in you an updated apps this
week check out social augmentation
Sona and a new update from whether I've
classic The Weather Channel that's all
for this week in Android development my
name is ready Maya thanks for watching